I think there's something here
that's not meant to be
it's the 10th year anniversary of The
Conjuring
wanna play hide and clap
it is amazing
we've created this universe that has
such a huge fan base the demon nun
really captured the Zeitgeist the first
film was set in Romania in 1952 and four
years later it's 1956 we find Sister
Irene she's hiding out in this Italian
Convent Irene thought that she left
phallic in her past
out of nowhere she gets a call from the
cardinal
Sister Irene
from the miracle
church music
the demon has used her old friend's body
to escape Romania
valak uses Maurice to try and find an
old Relic in the hands of a demon it
would be Unthinkable
valak is moving across Europe
killing these people
these victims must be protecting a
secret it really starts to connect
characters from The Conjuring universe
and bring them together it's also filled
with demonic forms that we haven't seen
before
it's okay
it would be great to uh eventually bring
it back full circle bring the non-story
and tie it back into The Conjuring
thank you
the nun chapter 2 only in theater
September 8th get tickets now